you're a single fellow yeah you're very
you're famous you're you're good-looking
you're single I got a husband you must
be dating all the time it must be
amazing being separating a little bit
started we get set up on some blind
dates by some friends I went on a date
the other a couple weeks ago and I was I
was early for the date sheet she was uh
she texted me she was late and Chris
Martin who's a friend of mine from
Coldplay I've known him forever he walks
into the restaurant and I we're catching
up and he's being he couldn't be a
sweeter guy and he notices my date isn't
there yet and he says um what's going on
I sell my dates a little late she is
texting me I'm on my phone it's a first
date it's kind of awkward I'm a little
anxious he goes do you want me to come
by the table and pretend I don't know
you and be like I'm your biggest fan in
the entire world I'm like yeah this
sounds this sounds amazing I'd be great
if you did that right yeah so he leaves
and my date arrives and we're having a
great dinner and I'm thinking in the
back of my head like oh he'll probably
just like to make a joke on the way out
of the restaurant but we're laughing my
date and I see behind her head he's
coming back and he makes eye contact
with me he goes and I'm like oh my god
this is really gonna happen yeah and he
comes over and you are you sack breath
oh yeah I am your biggest fan because
all of my music is inspired by
he's like scrubs got me through the
hardest times of my life made me wanna
write music yeah yeah and my date is
just like oh my god I can't leave this
is happening
he goes you guys are so cute together I
hope this works out and then he and then
he takes off and he's like off skips off
into the skip that's the one thing he
did wrong the one thing he did wrong
well blowing me I'm off it was amazing
because my day was like I can't believe
this just happened yeah I know it
happened I got to be honest it happens a
lot you know did you ever tell her of
course I didn't want to be like we mean
of course I would never have told her
that's the difference between genuine I
let it I let it sit for a good couple
minutes then I was like okay I got to be
odda kept that going for a year I would
after he walked away I would have said
who was then yeah after he like sold the
hell out of it she was like yeah I know
and I felt bad I had I had no could not
have kept it going still years later out
of Meritor been like hold on hello Chris
Martin again
you